thus car tester montas kirat looks at
the new mercedes vito and another new
Vito and yet another nuvid annoy a veto
on the instant diamond corporation
offers more than 1,000 different ways to
put together your own personalized
midsize vans I'm not sazaa monster
hunter it's a taxi the car maker
demonstrated this versatility when it
premiered the white van in an old power
station in Berlin it's a careers van or
a company bus
the rear-wheel drive version with a
strong engine can carry heavy loads
while the eight seat version can shuttle
a full volleyball team the veto is the
only vehicle in its segment to offer a
choice of front rear or all-wheel drive
ben de kun get some pokemon in Vega
mercedes-benz explains that a heavy-duty
vehicle up to 3.2 tons total weight puts
a heavy load on the rear axle looking
and trailer to it puts even more weight
on the rear axle so this clearly
requires a rear wheel drive but for a
lower total weight vehicle even at
maximum load there's much to recommend a
front-wheel drive if you only ever drive
around town then of course front wheel
drive is definitely the proper choice we
stole this one done given it absolutely
still odd the veto came onto the market
with two engine options both Diesel's a
1.6 litre with a 65 or 84 kilowatts of
power for front-wheel drive and a 2.1
litre diesel with three power ratings
for rear and all-wheel drive a few
changes have also been made to the
interior compared with the predecessor
model
I'm not my second auto [ __ ] Mornhinweg
points out that great attention was
given to optimal economic design for the
driver that is the sitting position the
position of the steering wheel the
pedals Mercedes as we worked everything
the bulkhead for instance was designed
so taller people can lean about
centimeters farther back and be more
comfortable riding in the van what's
team I saima cool and fought like father
and cut goblin and there are three
stowage spaces over the instrument
cluster that are partially covered to
minimize reflections from the windscreen
human thought of inches high pocket now
the front is a bit steeper to offer
better protection for pedestrians the
cargo space posts and intelligent
seating rail and locking systems the
headlights are available in halogen or
LED lights with taillights to match the
rear can be accessed through either a
hatchback tailgate or twin doors now
mercedes is offering two sliding doors
for the veto
montes sums up saying the 3dr concepts
front wheel rear wheel and all will make
for lots of versatility and a lower
price tag fuel consumption has been
improved with 5.7 liters being the best
rating for this series and currently the
best and the entire class but as soon as
the competitors bring out their latest
models all bets are off and Mercedes
developers will have to step on the gas
emissions Tom Mison dish farms is not to
leach out and incumbent on Yavin in
cycling